did leak shout out to kd shout out to
kevin durant i saw katie at your crib
we're gonna talk about your relationship
with katie
as a basketball fan i have a very
unfavorable opinion on kd but i do
i do recognize let's talk about that i
do recognize we just talk basketball
listen
gibbs i recognize they get that that
katie's been a big supporter of yours
for a long time
so he gets my pass shout out to kd man
k.d is like
my you know that's like one of my
brothers man i love him he's been a big
supporter i admire him uh like give him
you know you can't give a [ __ ] with 600
million dollars advice
but you could you could be like hey bro
you know what i mean it's love man i
just try to just you know
just provide you know just you know the
homie vibe i [ __ ] with homie
and you know we watch basketball talk
about life
and that's it my [ __ ] like we real you
know that's that's my real home you know
you know i know a lot of [ __ ] that
play basketball and a lot of [ __ ] that
hoop
a lot of [ __ ] in the nfl i know some
[ __ ] that [ __ ] play tennis i
know some soccer [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying but like you
know kev me and
me like kevin me and kevin is like real
friends he's been a big supporter of
yours for
a long time shout out to my [ __ ] that's
my dog
no man like with that being said what
are your thoughts on his move with the
warriors
what do you mean i'm just i'm just
curious because from a strictly
basketball perspective here you know
i'm impartial i'm partial bro so
anything
that unbiased perspective here i'm
biased i mean you are are you saying
anything that bro do i support okay so
anything when he did that [ __ ]
i was already i i was supporting it
anything he wanted to do
you know i support it you know i mean
like um
i think that you know you can know
somebody from a fan standpoint when you
know them
on a personal standpoint it's different
everything's different
you know what i mean like bro like you
you know you could have looking at
things different you see things
different you know what i mean
like and i don't like having
friends and stuff that i can't learn
from and build from because like i just
told you like when you stop being a
student in the game
that's when you [ __ ] up you know i'm a
student of life
so you know you my friend i learn [ __ ]
from you every time i come around you we
just talking about dick pills
hey listen if you're in the l.a area
and you need viagra what i'm saying i
got the 100 milligrams get at me
what i'm saying is you know and then
wrong with it listen
it ain't a lot of people basically what
i'm saying [ __ ] the space
that let you know how good of friends we
are exactly because we could talk
differently and a lot of people that i
call michael
you're one of my close friends ken you
know what i'm saying like you know
kd that's a close friend of mine so you
know i learned when i go around homies
and i i learn from them
you know i mean you know and vice versa
you know what i mean so you know i don't
i don't i don't really [ __ ] with nobody
that i can't soak no gamer from you know
what i mean and we we both soak up a
game from each other you know i mean me
and you me and kd
all my [ __ ] that i [ __ ] with kevin's
exact couple of kevin
shout out to kd shout out to kd i hope i
meet him one day
and and i take a photo with him so all
my friends the [ __ ] warriors
women won the [ __ ] last couple
championships without him anyway [ __ ]
exactly they wouldn't have
he'll [ __ ] know all that [ __ ]
let's put it into that debate
let's put it into that [ __ ] [ __ ] i agree
because
the [ __ ] i could see if he went there
and he was just a piece no
no no no sam went there and became
finals mvp
two times in a row